june shows coming up hollywood june 4th
i'm at the troubadour it's going to be a
really cool show june 24th i'm in des
moines iowa one night only june 25th
headed to omaha nebraska one night only
and back at brea california
june 30th one night only as well get
your tickets to those shows and all
shows at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media and i want to say thank you again
every week this show continues to grow i
i appreciate all the love the support
thank you so much please subscribe to
the youtube
uh means nothing to you and everything
to us i promise you you want a free way
to help the show if you're watching just
hit that damn thing it's that easy if
you gotta have more hit up the patreon
it's five bucks a month it's called the
honeydew with y'all and i'm highlighting
the lowlights with y'all and you all
have some
wild [ __ ] stories i i can't
you gotta go watch the promos you gotta
watch we got [ __ ] going on all over the
place cold case is getting solved some
getting created two [ __ ] going to one
[ __ ] like it's a lot of [ __ ] yeah it's
a lot of [ __ ] going down over there five
bucks a month if you sign up for a year
you get over a month free um and you get
the honey do a day early ad free at no
additional cost all right that's the biz
right there um you know what we do over
here we highlight the low lights i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers and i'm very excited to
have this guest on today for the first
time here ladies and gentlemen please
welcome corinne fisher welcome to the
honeydew for corey thank you for you all
thank you i love it i love it um can i
ask you first why did you call it the
honeydew yes because it is the fruit i
see it i'm looking at pictures of it
right now it is a good it's an
underrated fruit i would say too that's
nice you say yeah i truly love it why
this is so the whole thing so these are
fan-submitted pictures okay um
of
a perfectly good fruit
right that's tossed aside
one night i was having dinner by myself
in a diner and i ate my fruit cup and i
ate everything but the honeydew you did
i did um um i even ate the the [ __ ]
that red grape i like green grapes but i
even ate that one red grape okay right
and as i got up and i walked out i just
looked across the tables and i saw
honeydew
everywhere that's literally making me
very sad right now and i was like wow
this is a perfectly good fruit that
people just it's not that i have this
hate against it i always say it's not i
just don't [ __ ] with it okay and then
it's like the iceberg lettuce of the
fruit world you know what i mean it's
just water right and then i realized
like oh my god that's
me that's you i'm a perfectly good
person who's been thrown away time and
time again oh that got real sad real
fast and that's why it's called the
honeydew and that's why we highlight the
low level okay i knew there was going to
be a good reason i just couldn't exactly
figure it out without that's my favorite
one the cigarette in the [ __ ]
i was like i love honeydew i would
totally eat just a pile of honeydew i
feel like it's only good i've researched
it so there's like one month a year it's
like good yeah well maybe that's the
problem so it never really got time to
shine
well first of all thank you for being
here it's been i've been a huge fan for
a long time y'all don't even know i know
you're on the new york side of things
um will you please plug promote
everything and anything you'd like yeah
sure so well christina hutchinson and i
my comedy partner we are mainly in town
right now to promote uh the comedy
special that we just released on youtube
it's called our special day it's a half
hour of stand up from both christina and
myself separately and then we give you a
taste of what guys we [ __ ] the live
experience is like when we take our show
on the road so there's some a segment
called seven minutes in therapy where
people
bring problems in front of large crowds
and we solve them um
and then there's also a segment called
sexting theater where we do dramatic
readings of people's sex messages and
this is all like this is not produced
segments this is literally just fans of
the show in the audience who are willing
to come up and over share
um and i directed the special as well so
i'm very excited about that yeah
congrats thanks yeah i'm like i have a
bfa in directing so let's you know start
using it my team actually my agent was
like do you want to direct it because i
was good at thinking about that you're
gonna pay me well it wasn't even about
the money i know yeah it wasn't about
the money i didn't get paid any extra um
but i was so excited to have that credit
because it's something that i really
need to cover where do you have your
degree from um sva school of visual arts
right so yeah pretty pretty good school
is that your directorial debut in the
prof in the professional world uh
i've yeah i mean i've done some like
web series for other comedians and some
like off off broadway plays in new york
but
it's definitely the thing that i think
is going to get the most attention so i
was happy to do it man okay so you have
quite a range then artistically which is
pretty impressive well i think what it's
less of it's less that i have a range
and more that i have like i mean i sit
across from comedians every week
well it's like i'm an artist but i have
my i really have my [ __ ] together and i
think most artists don't like i for like
i make a great assistant which i think
almost no comedians could say that about
themselves but it's it's kind of bad
when you're a couldn't be a good
assistant because
uh then people want you to be the
assistant
because your shit's together right so i
i always
say that you should have your [ __ ] not
together so that the only choice you
have is to do the art and no one wants
you to do anything else because you will
[ __ ] it up amen yeah
all right so some people come on they
tell a life story right some people come
on tell what an experience whatever i
want to know a little bit about uh your
background of course where you're from
and how you grow up and things but i
really want to hear about this last four
years you emailed us about okay my life
story like i don't have like an
interesting childhood story anyway
because i had a nice childhood so
there's not like i always tell people on
interviews i'm like i know you guys love
to suck these sad stories out of
comedians i had a mom and a dad who
remained married until my dad died we
had dogs i have a little brother who's
an engineer and we grew up in
suburban new jersey union new jersey
shout out to artie lange and
my childhood was not i'm sure like artie
lange's at all most childhoods were yeah
yeah and um and also ray liotta also
from union okay so that's it gives you a
sense of the kind of place that i'm
coming from uh robert wool arless uh and
uh yeah and then
things got more out of control when i
was released by myself into the real
world because i moved to new york city
when i was 17. so so where's your love
from the for the arts were you also uh
did you play sports were you athletic as
well did i play sports or did sports
play me i mean i played you know
basketball at the
boys and girls club but i mean the sport
i played i don't even know if i would
consider it a sport it you know you get
a varsity letter for it but i was a
baton twirler oh and the um that was my
guard no color guard is different color
guard no offense is for dorks um uh
baton twirling is i'll tell you what we
call them later
but tan swirling buttons rolling isn't
popular um in the northeast it's mostly
a southern thing okay but
in new jersey we did have um
a lot of twirling competition so i was
lucky i just really like it it's like
cheerleading but you have a stick in
your hand never heard of it have you
heard of that at other high schools
baton twirling yeah not in i mean not
really in my area there was a couple
surrounding towns i went to ms patty's
paddy's dolls baton twirling school
there was a there's a school for that
show
yes
out there
yeah it was oh god this is like taking
me down memory lane i loved patty's
dolls
but it was like the school was just like
this church room that they rented out
you know on weekdays at 3 p.m
and you because you just needed a place
with really high ceilings because you
need to be able to throw batons i was
just about to ask yeah and i mean it was
like i think it was those kind of
ceilings where you know when you hit it
the the the block moves i don't know
what that's called but that little tile
yeah it's like you're not gonna break
anything but it looks [ __ ] up when you
look up so yeah we went to i went to
patty's dolls uh baton twirling school
and uh that was the sport that i played
i was also in all the school plays um
one of the you know editors of the
newspaper that you know futures future
business leaders of america i've been an
overachiever since i was born all right
overachiever i'm gonna ask you straight
up right now somebody said
thousand bucks could you go out front
twirl that [ __ ] as high as you
could and grab that baton today could i
grab it could you still do what you did
at your best oh at my best i wasn't that
good so yes
like could i catch it i guess just
because you love stuff don't mean you
have to be great at it yeah i know i
love lots of things i'm not good at
i would also like even like there's
video of me literally like going like
this as i turn cover it up yeah
because it hurts to get whacked with a
metal stick with that old uh crutch that
look look like the crutch tips on me i
know those white rubber ones that are
hard as [ __ ] and i and i in my high
school uh we twirled fire so what yeah
you could never do that now uh no i
think this is like new jersey yeah it is
jersey yeah you just we literally just
dumped the ends in kerosene and ignited
it my favorite part of it is because i'm
an italian juice so i have hairy arms
and it would sting all your arm hair off
so it's like a free waxing
i love that part every i would look
forward to it i'm like around thank you
you said you weren't even that good so
you're throwing a fiery [ __ ] baton up
in the air and i wasn't that good but i
was competent i could catch it
my parents would just make fun of me
because i like everyone else would throw
it so high and sometimes they would drop
out i would always throw it like two
inches above my head but i said did i
not always catch it yeah right right
it's like what do we want do we want
success or do we want to try to be the
best at this
i was like i want to catch it and then
move on with my dad
there's no future in twirling what are
we doing i was just doing it for fun i
hate what i hate about childhood is that
all the things i loved how to become
competitive i love gymnastics and then
all of a sudden you know then we need to
train so hard that i'm gonna skip a
period i just like tumbling i just like
tumbling
it's insane violin it's like
like
can anything just be fun without it
having to be
you have to be the best at it and have
some kind of monetary future in it just
like have a little bit of fun this is
why i don't think i've ever had fun i
mean also that's how that's part of how
i grew up
and um
my parents only took us on educational
vacations so that's right okay so listen
so far your childhood sounds kinda
little uh not so great no it really was
therapists always try to pry and i go no
i'm not trying to pray it's true
it's truly wrong like man it's always
educational which ends up in hindsight
it is great yeah i i would love for my
daughter to be like remember that time
to smithsonian and [ __ ] yes over that
time we
we walked to edgar allan poe's house in
baltimore oh yeah i've been to a lot of
edgar i don't know edgar allen poe lived
various places um
you know in the northeast but i uh yeah
we went to his house and it's not a safe
area now listen i'm from baltimore and i
wanted to tell you yeah i'm from
baltimore and i had field trips there
quite often which all of us would be
like are we have a real one coming down
this wait you're accident that's
baltimore i mean mine feels so southern
mind i get a lot of that but mine's not
as hard as like stavros and i'll do that
okay hon it's not like mine he's from
d.c
baltimore oh he's baltimore okay that's
interesting yeah okay so um
we would go there all the time and and
so you know so they would leave there
was money around at one time and i was
like oh my gosh oh no you stole from
edgar allan poe's memorial i started too
it's great and then the [ __ ]
teacher's like and if you ever take
money from here it's bad luck and we
were like yeah
yeah yeah okay guys and we added
something here you go yeah
not a good neighborhood not a safe
neighborhood to be taking some kids in
well it's funny because it's a it's a
predominantly black area and
and anytime um the people in the
neighborhood saw
white people walking through they would
they would just shout at the white
people edgar allan poe's houses this
time
which i thought was very charming
and welcoming and nice
i was like thanks that is exactly why
i'm here
um
all right so i don't get an email like
this a lot these things that happened
all in the last four years really yeah
not not in the span of four years but i
can appreciate it because in the span of
four years
i lost both of my grandmothers a girl
who was like my sister
um and then my dad and grandmother i
mean that was all in five six years
right my grandpa also died i just didn't
even add that i mean
in the past four years yeah i have a
friend of mine her name is carlotta wood
she does the the voiceover for the show
she's the one that announces the show
for all you that ask all the time and i
still say and you still ask
but she came on and
told me this quote she had heard um and
it's and she said
i'm glad i don't look like what i've
been through
and i was like man oh man wow
so
tell me
what has happened to you in the last
four years do you want to go in
chronological order please okay so it
started in
[Music]
2018 where i'm like can i do math yes it
started in 2018 i was in um like a two
and a half year relationship with who i
still consider this day even though i
hate him and have a joke in my special
about how i hope him and his wife die
but separately so it's not romantic
and i mean it and it feels good to say
it every time and i'll never stop saying
it
even though a litigator did say you
might want to stop
beautiful
you might want to stop saying that i
said but i can't um
and uh
and so he that was you know during the
time when
so it was right after the 2016 election
and and i i was dating this person
before we knew uh trump was running
against hillary clinton
and
when it was announced you know he was
selected uh
as the nominee
i found out that the person i was you
know dating already in love with was a
donald trump supporter of course in 2016
we didn't know what that meant yet we
had an idea but we had no idea where it
was gonna go
and
i wasn't like i didn't hold that against
him i i i am very open i have another
podcast besides guys we [ __ ] call
without a country where the whole
purpose of it is to read news from the
left the right
and i'll go to an anarchist website
anything
and just try to get a sense of the truth
i don't care what feels good or what you
want the story to be
i truly do try to be a truth seeker in
anything i want facts i want stats that
includes things that we talk about on
guys we [ __ ] like sex work i'm like i
don't want to know in an ideal world the
uh the effects of sex work i want to
know how does sex work really affect
women and men but mostly women now um
and
so we started
we you know were both very into politics
and i talked about it on guys we [ __ ]
because i thought it would be really
interesting that two people
who were so adamant about two political
candidates different political
candidates were were dating and how we
were going to navigate that
um and it was very poorly received i was
actually really surprised by how no it
was poorly received by the listeners of
guys we [ __ ] like immediately they
were like you because it was that that
era of like you have to
dump this person because he feels
politically different than you
but we had you know it's not like i
don't have these conversations with
people before i get in relationships for
me
the two main things i need to know about
you
uh are are you pro-choice because we're
gonna be having sex like that's i don't
understand how you can have a partner
who feels differently about that one
because that's something that could
happen so you need to know that um and
then secondly what are your feelings on
lgbtq plus you know stuff because i have
a lot of gay friends and
you meeting my gay friends is
more important than you meeting my
parents like if that doesn't go well
this can't work um
and he was fine with both of those
things i took him to a gay club early on
because it's like there's one thing to
say you're fine and then there's another
thing to like take you into a space
where you're going to actively be hit on
by men and i think it really shows i
just want to ask you who you are gay
club so tell me is this uh it was more
men than women oh yeah yeah no yeah it's
there's very few uh lesbian clubs is
that right there's not a lot lesbians
aren't really known for like partying
i know all my gay friends tell me
lesbians are like as soon as they meet
that what is what's the joke they show
up with a u-haul like they're just like
[ __ ] party we're moving in yeah
no so i'm always i was like i was raised
in gay clubs i do credit drag queens
with part of the reason that i'm a
comedian no one's funnier no one's more
brazen no one's more in your face a drag
queen could make any comedian cry on any
given day
um
yeah and so
all the i know everything lined up and i
had never felt so un understood in my
entire life that's a problem like i do
this you know show where we have really
deep conversations with people people
are telling us about their you know
their rapes their traumas and
i've
i have sympathy for all these people
and i have empathy but i don't
i don't a lot of people's experiences
and the way they see the world more
importantly than their experiences don't
resonate with me you know people will be
sitting
and telling me a story like you know
when someone says something to you and
you just can't stop thinking about it
and i'm like not really like in a way
that it negatively affects you like you
keep thinking like i should have said
something different and i go no i don't
really know what you're talking talking
about i don't spend a lot of time
thinking of things that i could have or
should have said i just try to
say the thing i'm really mean right off
the bat and then i don't have that
problem i don't know i just always felt
alien and now i have since learned it's
apparently because i had a nice
childhood and i love myself which was a
while to learn that at like 30 i was
like i thought most people loved
themselves and it was a few people who
were working on it but that little
information right there just talked
about this yesterday i'm like is this
what it feels like to like yourself oh
you don't like yourself and it's not
that i don't like myself honestly i
should take that back i do love myself
but i'm
not used to having good so my mind is
always right when is that when's when's
the other foot gonna drop right that's
where i'm always at it's just like um i
mean i feel like i know what i mean yeah
i mean i'm i i'm not used to feeling
right i'm jewish i mean i'm always
expecting a bad thing to happen but
positive all the time yeah i'm not sorry
i'm like oh this is what it's like to
feel nice yeah i'm glass half empty for
sure but it doesn't like weigh on me it
took journaling for me to finally get
the glass half empty
yeah to get to glass fmt yeah i was
always glass
wait no glass half empty glass half full
i was like that's yours
didn't work then
that's her i'm backfired that was so
positive before that's so funny no i am
now um
half full but it took
it took writing and writing but it's
interesting because the therapist i i
was talking to yesterday she goes you
know just human nature we go negative
first so she goes that's interesting
statistically you have to have two
thoughts to make a positive thought
because our inclination is humans it's
just what the way we're wired is
something negative okay let's think
something positive but we've got to do
the work to be able to even think let's
have another thought about this and
let's not make it a second negative
thought right let's go positive right it
took me a while to get there yeah and i
don't bat a thousand
but it took me a while to get there yeah
yeah no i can only imagine i don't know
but yeah so do wait
yeah the loving yourself it's just so
everyone looks at me like like they
can't believe that i didn't know most
people didn't love themselves but i
think that's because i like took people
at their word a lot of the time and most
people
are kind of walking through life and
pretending and saying things as if they
do believe in themselves and are
confident and i didn't realize that most
of that was fake and i'm not
i'm not a naive person i just
for me it's just so so like why like it
just seems like such honestly a pain in
the ass to lie lying to me
is such a pain in the ass because you
have to remember the all these stories
that you told are that are untrue it's
not like i'm on
my high horse being like the truth is
the best option no it's the easiest it's
easy
i have other things i want to work on i
can't remember a web of lies all the
time i'm gonna get tripped up and i'm
gonna say the wrong thing i'm gonna have
a drink and i'm gonna say the wrong
thing you know i'm gonna say the lie but
if you're always saying the truth then
there's no other there's no mistakes to
be made um
yeah so i was you know so things don't
resonate me whatever i was confused and
um
i don't even know how i got here but i
always somehow get here uh yeah and uh
the relationship went went on and on and
it became more other people had a
problem with it that's what you were
saying
or no the fans were like you can't you
got it you can't do that on you and then
also it you know i have this outlet
every week and it made me not want to
share anything because i thought it
would be really cool to share
share a love story of people from two
different political parties like i
thought it was gonna be great um
and then i just ended up having to
kind of hide my relationship and if we
did get in a fight about politics i felt
like i couldn't talk about it to anyone
because at first it was fans and then it
was friends and then it was family
and so when you have a relationship no
matter how good it's going and you can't
talk about anything that's going wrong
in it and at this time i wasn't in
therapy yet
like the stuff just bubbles inside you
um
and
then
he started
reading a lot of reddit threads and
that's how all horror movies should
start i mean that's not good for anybody
yeah and this person that i love so much
i saw his mental health like devolving
he's a smart person
but it's like he was getting sucked into
conspiracy theories and
but it was happening kind of before
all the q and stuff and the widespread
things that we knew were happening
especially on the right
um and i just saw like i just saw his
brain being lost to politics right in
front of my eyes and i don't even know
how to put it into words correctly
because i haven't fully processed it
myself yet because i don't think
until i quarantine when i was sitting
alone for a long time did i realize how
deeply that time had affected me
but it really was what i imagined like
losing a parent to dementia or having
someone's like schizophrenia really come
to a head because it was this person
that you love and this person the person
i felt like i knew most in my entire
life this person who finally understood
me who i could say really anything to
without judgment and he would get it i
could come home and say the most [ __ ]
up things the
craziest thoughts i had the
um most void of ethics thoughts i had
and he would always um understand and
that person's
like beautiful mind was just being lost
to
something that i didn't even feel was
noble just i don't feel any part of
politics or particularly noble so that
was the issue it's not like it's not
like he had you know gone crazy because
he went to save children from an
orphanage that was on fire and he was
traumatized or something like that like
that i could have stayed through
um but it was it was scary it it really
felt like there was a stranger
in my house we didn't live together but
he was there enough that
i was a stranger in my house and to
i don't it's like it's you're watching
someone die or morph into another person
in front of you what's the moment where
you really
were like all right this has to end like
that you knew
it was it was there was not one singular
moment this is a person that i i had to
dump three times for it to finally stick
and then one day we were just sitting on
my couch watching a movie and i c if the
whole time you're sitting there you're
thinking i have to break up with this
person i have to break up with this
person i have to break up with this
person i just came out i go we this has
to i just looked over and he was on his
phone i'm sure again on reddit
doing god knows what uh you know reading
breitbart or whatever and uh and like it
listen i read brave part two because i
want to know what's going on but i don't
like take everything that they say
seriously
nor do i take everything that the new
york times says seriously um and uh
yeah and i and then i said you have you
have to go and then it unraveled so much
worse from there i found out
that he had um cheated on me during the
time when i was trying to break up with
him and
which is so hurtful because it's like i
tried to break up with you you begged to
stay in the relationship and then
cheated on me i now again know more from
talking about relationships every week
that cheating is often a reflection on
the person doing the cheating not the
person being cheated on
um and i am definitely someone who when
i stop connecting with you i can get
very cold
and i know especially straight men need
a lot i need a lot of like love
um
outward love that i think
is that women don't need as much like a
lot of like you're great a lot of
cuddling that kind of stuff i'm not good
at that um and it definitely gets worse
when i feel distant from you because the
moment
i feel disconnected from someone
it's there's real it's a very hard for
that to come back
because i'm protecting myself at this
point i'm like you don't understand me
anymore and so i'm not going to share
any more of myself with you it's over
um
but
yeah i'm so that's like something that
i'm still
mourning and he ends up marrying someone
uh who looks just like me
who's a younger comedian
i had a lot of feminist issues with that
um because it felt like he was just
doing like you know go
marrying me with less opinions
so within the span of what two years he
gets married yeah yeah split and married
yeah mm-hmm to a girl who looks just
like you yeah yeah very small it's lit
it's you know you you there's a we all
have a type but sure
you'd all be in a lineup yes we'd all go
to the same audition
absolutely
yeah
yes yes
and it was weird because even though he
was this you know trump supporter he was
uh always liked to date these very
liberal feminist checks
so
like the first photo i saw of his now
wife she was wearing
you know
a nasty
what is it nasty woman what was it what
did you call hillary clinton
you know and then they meet all that
merch and then i forgot about it because
it was so awful that i just pushed it
out of my head and like the [ __ ] the
pink [ __ ] hat
and i was like this is like a even i'm
not this feminist because even i make
fun of these feminists because it's just
like i don't know it feels too branded
to me feminists is like let's light
something on fire that's the kind of
feminist i am let's ignite a man no
you could
that's your background from the batons
yeah fire right through that's where it
is that's fire in you yeah yeah well i
always say you say i was like more
malcolm x than martin luther king i'm
like let's really [ __ ] get [ __ ] done
a quiet march no thank you
um so he didn't try to fight for the
relationship or anything when by the
time it had come and you said they're
dumping it no but i mean he did do kinds
of things where like i would block him
on social media so that i could heal
because it's hard even when you do the
jumping it's hard to see another person
move on and live their life that's
difficult and especially when it's
someone like i've never had to do that
before so
it was break up and if they're out of
your circle they're gone maybe you ran
into them somewhere down the line or
whatever but you didn't see every
[ __ ] thing they ate yeah did said
after that i mean i was zooming in in on
plates to see if there was a woman's
reflection in them it was bad i can't be
doing that that's not good for my mental
health at least you're honest about it
yeah i have obsessive compulsive
disorder and it really it really gets
flared up uh with with breakups badly so
i just you know i just ruminate over all
the other things that i could have done
differently which kind of is the impetus
for guys we [ __ ] because i'm such a
i'm like in like at the core an a an a
plus student so i look at everything
that way how could i have aced that
relationship you know how could i have
how could i've done it it's just like
it's constant like win-win-win success
success success to the point where i'm
like am i even enjoying this moment and
then that's how i got into psychedelics
but you know that's a whole different
that's a happy story so we don't
talk about that here um
yeah and uh
you know i had to explain to him that
sometimes we need to block people for
ourselves not because i'm like this
isn't about you you know i need to heal
now because you have traumatized me um
and then yeah there was just a series of
like phone calls you know after i i
started started dating someone else uh i
was happy
um
i hadn't talked to this person anymore
and then out of the blue he calls me to
let me know that he's now
in a serious relationship with this
woman he would go on to marry like you
don't why why
exactly
exactly it was a gaslighting call you
know gaslighting is overused now but
you know and he the worst part was he
started the conversation by going how
are you just want to see how you're
doing
i like excitedly tell them about my life
this is the person i love this is a
person who i would wanted to consider a
friend in the future for 30 minutes
that's nice you yeah you still were
there you were still there though yeah i
cared like i knew i had to distance
myself from this person but i was really
sad about his mental health i just
couldn't i couldn't do anything more
about it i mean i offered to
pay for therapy because i had more money
than him at the time was still um and uh
and so i offered to help pair him with a
therapist to pay for that but that's
something that you have to really want
to do and he did go once but you know
once doesn't doesn't solve it i was
there like i was like i'm ready to go in
the trenches with you i want to make
this work like you are my team teammate
and i give a [ __ ] about you and i never
really felt that way about anyone
romantically before friends for for sure
um
but at a certain point you're like well
either we're both gonna go down with
this ship or i'm gonna have to leave you
on the ship to drown or swim to shore or
just [ __ ] figure it out and i
ultimately cuz i mean at that time my
health was suffering like i look at
pictures of me from that time it's like
i look older than i do now i look my
skin is just like breaking out i'm
overweight like it's it's it was the
relationship was killing me and i didn't
even know until like two years after how
bad
it had gotten
um
i think oh actually i think the the
moment when i knew knew knew we had to
break up was i had taken him to denver
we were christine and i were playing
comedy works denver and we got this
amazing opportunity to open for dave
chappelle oh man and our our you know i
guess it was uh our anniversary my ex
and i our anniversary was around that
time he's a comic too or was i don't
think he does it anymore um and we
uh
and i was like i took him on this trip
and like the first thing is like we get
on the plane i'm paid for everything we
get on the plane you know he's
complaining about where we're sitting on
the plane
about the amount of room that we have
and i'm not [ __ ] flying spirit it was
delta
like yeah it was main cabin but i didn't
have as much money at that time and like
so i'm like bill yeah
who who complains about seriously just
like that kind of stuff like i will i
will spend ten thousand dollars on
summit and all you have to do is not
complain that's all i ask i will plan
the trip you all you have to do is come
and the only thing i ask of you is that
you don't [ __ ] complain and that
seems like a really hard request for a
lot of boyfriends
and you know what also i have to look in
the mirror because why am i dating these
people but whatever um
and and so yeah that that trip um
with you know kind of like the final
test like can this work out and
obviously it couldn't work out so right
after we came home um i dumped him and i
was like so mad i was like i can't
believe i introduced you to dave
chappelle but it's fine it's okay um so
that was that was the moment but yeah
this is not like this it's hard to again
like verbalize this because
i i don't exactly know the answer or how
i'm gonna resolve this in my own life
it's something i still talk about in
therapy to this day and it's something
that no matter i i was having nightmares
about this person for i still do
sometimes like
what is it a recurring nightmare not a
recurring nightmare but just always like
me having to defend myself against this
person like physically you know
which is something that never happened
right in the relationship i don't want
to put that out there but um
yeah just it's like it truly feels
i've gotten very into woo woo as a lot
of white women did during quarantine and
but yeah i will say that i've always
been into wicca since i was like in the
seventh grade so just so when it's not
all new but like i did like learn how to
read tarot in the past year real quick
is that a donnie darko ring no it's not
people think it is um it's uh from this
australian company uh called heart of
bone okay uh but yeah billy eilish made
these these popular i actually just like
i i work with them now a little bit but
i truly just love the jewelry so
i like a you know it was stand up yeah i
like a ring because when you're holding
the microphone
um
but uh
yeah wiccan yeah wiccan and um and uh
it's not new to you it's not new to me
and so i felt like there was it was like
they were trying he was trying to
infiltrate
my dreams at this point you know it's
like i've cut him off on all social
media he wrote me an email at one point
um you know defending his now wife
because i was like not chatting with her
in comedy clubs when she would come by
which is a wild suggestion man
and you know they were mad because i was
talking about them on guys we [ __ ]
never never her by name him by name
because he had been on the show and
agreed to it and he's a public person
and he you don't have a protection like
that when you're public person as long
as i'm telling the truth which i was
um and uh
yeah and i was like well it's
interesting that now's the time that you
decide to
you know protect a woman but because you
certainly didn't protect me mentally and
i ended that email with um never ever
contact me again and i really meant it
and even though i was like oh you know
it'd be nice if you did
really work for it but um and he hasn't
contacted me since uh but yeah i replied
with the
meanest
um
email that i've ever written to anyone
now how many how long ago was that now
since that last email um
maybe
2020 early 20s 20s
so have you have you dated again you
said you oh yeah lots of people
yeah but if you had a boyfriend again
someone who felt like this no no and
then yeah and there's there's the
problem of course you know i mean i take
i say breakups really hard because i
think i really never connect with anyone
the only person
who i felt who i had met during since i
broke up with him that i felt like i
could possibly connect with on that
level
um
was a chef
named carl famous chef actually he's
like on all those guy fiery grocery
games carl rose and kind of a friend of
the new york comedy community
um i met him doing a podcast
and
we really connected like i love chefs
number one it's like it has been it's
very on record that it is my goal in
life to date and marry a shop
i love shopping
i love them i love food all i do is
watch
the food network um and i feel like
there's a couple occupations that really
get along with comedians and one of them
it's like chef sex worker
and comedian all go together really well
in a way that even musicians i've dated
musicians and i thought they would get
comedy they they don't um
but uh
i met him and i
i
never immediately connect with someone i
never christina is a great pairing for
me because we're always sitting down at
the podcast table she can find something
in common with a chair and that is a
gift and god bless her and i look that's
why we make such a good team but i
week after week stare people and dead
and i just have dead eyes and i and i
know that but just i find their stories
interesting and i think about them a lot
but
nothing they say resonates with me in
any way i feel like we're on different
planes and so i mean i feel that when
words come out of my mouth they go is
she talking gobbledygook like what the
[ __ ] did this [ __ ] just say i feel that
way a lot with comedy but i think that's
why you know you try to think like why
am i comedian what [ __ ] up thing
happened that made me wanted to tell
jokes on stage and a couple years ago i
realized i was like oh
because when an audience laughs at your
jokes that's them connecting
to what you're saying so if i can't if i
continuously fail connecting with people
one-on-one at the very least i can
connect with people
um
from a little bit more of a distant
space and that's why i love comedy but
believe me in the process of writing
these jokes when i'm working them out
there's a lot of audience members
greeting me with dead eyes like
what like how is that a joke or what is
how is that relatable in any way
um and so i sat down and did a podcast
with this man carl and i
just connected with him immediately and
i get so excited because that never
happens i later found out he's from new
jersey which is number one of the number
one signs that i'm gonna get along with
you i'm from new jersey i really love
people from new jersey
there's just some kind of an unwritten
thing that we share my neighbor jen is
from jersey she's got a jersey tattoo
right here
jersey
jersey yeah and so we connected um he
hit me up after that podcast appearance
and was like i was nervous but like i
would like to take you on a date is that
okay i was like [ __ ] yes let's go on a
date
um
he
we you know we're texting back and forth
really getting to know each other we're
both busy i was i had to go to like jfl
toronto so we're just like you know it's
in that that part where you're just like
really getting to know each other but we
haven't gone on this official for a
state yet um
and he was planning some like
extravagant dinner at
one of rocco de spirito's restaurants
and like you're like wow this person's
like really [ __ ] putting in the work
um and he's like a big meat guy i don't
eat meat but he didn't he was so he was
putting together like a veg this
vegetarian thing and i was like what
like this person gives a [ __ ] i love i
love this he seems interested at his
home is this or did you go to a
restaurant his restaurant um it was
supposed to be one of rocco desperate
restaurants because i think he is one of
the chefs who i see who really has a
grasp on vegetarian cuisine because a
lot of uh
chefs kind of laugh at vegetarian
cuisine as if it is nothing without the
without the main protein um
but that the first date never happened
because when i even though we were
talking nonstop for a couple weeks i'm
in toronto um i wake up in the middle of
the night like five in the morning one
time i just i just i'm not a person who
wakes up in the middle i just woke up in
the middle of the night and i was like
looking around i look at my phone it's a
text from my friend the comedian ryan
reese he goes carl's gone
and i'm like well you know when you wake
up you go what the [ __ ] does that even
mean
what right what what is that what does
that mean and so
and then i finally like come out of like
my sleep state a little bit more and i'm
like is he [ __ ] dead so i'm googling
which is the good thing about when a
famous person dies you can check it real
quick um and
yeah he had he had gone
um
on a trip somewhere in the northeast and
uh
you know died of heart had a heart
attack in his sleep and his assistant
found him dead how old um
42 that's my dad's age when he died yeah
and so same [ __ ] i'm just there
i'm in another country which is not i
don't know there's just it feels it you
know when some someone you really care
about dies you want to be at home
i'm freaking out thank god i was on the
road at that time with rosebud baker who
is
really comfortable with death because
her sister
um passed away when she was very young
um drowned in a hot tub
can we just
yeah this i just talked about this so
about rosebud yeah rosebud doesn't even
know i know her rosebud doesn't even
know that her story has affected me so
much bursary affected me before i met
her yeah same i heard about like i have
wanted to have her on the show but i
don't know if i could sit here and
listen to it oh because i have my
daughter's seven now
and since she's been in pools and hot
tubs yeah because of that [ __ ] story
yeah i'm like don't you [ __ ] go under
you don't swim in here i don't care if
there's guards on that [ __ ] yeah and
well kids don't need to be in hot tubs
anymore yeah i mean what our friends got
to pull it's like right next to us they
hop back and forth you know what i mean
back and forth cold water hot water
playing i'm always out there though i
will right because of that [ __ ] story
and it runs through my goddamn mind and
i would like to have her on she's great
she'll be great i just it ain't anything
about her it's all about me like
i have this story in my head like oh my
god this happened and just awful yeah
yeah well i mean i think laws change
like i think because of because of that
the switch has to be accessible and
that's how i knew because i had heard
about a child drowning in a hot tub and
i had heard that that changed laws of
where the emergency switch needs to be
and then later on in life i would meet
rosebud and i would hear that story and
i was like that
has to be the same person it has to be
you know some of the things that helped
me jump start my day like workouts
meditation
uh journaling hydration they all clear
my head space give me energy all right
and when you push your body too hard or
you just feel run down it's extremely
important to stay hydrated so making
hydration a priority helps us feel
better on a day-to-day basis and what i
like most about liquid iv is how easy it
is to take with you no matter where you
are you just drop right in some water
you're good to go it's you can put it in
your pocket there's no excuse not to be
hydrated one stick of liquid iv
hydration multiplier in 16 ounces of
water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone it contains
five essential vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and
vitamin c with three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks it's made with premium
ingredients non-gmo and free from gluten
dairy and soy grab liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidity.com and use
the code honeydew at checkout that's 25
off of anything you order when you use
my promo code honeydew at liquidive.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidity.com promo code honeydew
understanding investing today can get
really confusing when people keep using
terms like meme stocks altcoin and
shilling with all the jargon flying
around it can be hard to figure out how
to start investing getting your money
right is easier with sofi the first
investing platform to offer stocks etfs
automated investing and cryptocurrency
too all in one app okay so i already
downloaded the app i've been going
through it i love it man you can invest
you have the option to do your banking
credit card track your finances and
check your credit score all right there
so whether eager to get started with
investing or you already know the ropes
and want to diversify your portfolio so
fi has your back there's no commissions
on trading stocks and etfs and plus
there are no account fees or hidden fees
use fractional shares that start as low
as five dollars to buy brand new stocks
even if you don't have a couple grand
lying around complimentary financial
planners are ready to help with any
questions whether you're stuck on where
to start or need help deciding what to
do next cut through the jargon and make
investing easier with sofi visit
sofi.com honeydew to learn how you can
win up to a thousand dollars in stock
when you open an account that's
sofi.com honeydew brokerage and active
investing products offered through sofi
securities llc member f i n r a slash s
i p c athletic greens is the health and
wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
simple with so many stressors in life
it's difficult to maintain effective
nutritional habits and give our body the
nutrients it needs to thrive i don't
care what you're doing whether you're
parenting i'm out there working like you
guys i'm touring and
you know i don't eat great so having
ag-1 there is a huge deal for me and as
the research changes so does ag-1 while
most nutritional products that come to
market never evolve athletic greens
continues to obsessively improve ag-1
based on the latest research producing
53 improvements over the last decade and
counting it's lifestyle friendly whether
you eat keto paleo vegan dairy-free or
gluten-free and it contains less than
one gram of added sugar no gmos no nasty
chemicals or artificial anything while
keeping it tasting good to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free
one year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs which i use all the
time with your first purchase if you
visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take control of your health
and give a g one a try now let's get
back to the do um but yeah rosebud and i
have uh danced around each other's
areas in life a long time before we
became really good friends uh we were on
we were on the same reality show even
though we never knew each other
yeah this show called uh uh
boys who like girls who like boys or
girls girls who like boys who like boys
um
it was on the sundance network it was a
reality show about straight women and
their gay best friends which i was
ultimately fired from because i my best
friend and i like i wouldn't pretend to
be uh in love with my gay best friend
and he wouldn't pretend to have a
terrible drug problem and so they were
like we need to go oh and i was like
well but why would we prote that's like
a heavy thing to pretend
on television that will affect our lives
and careers
but which would you have a drug which
would be drugs and also like house like
it's like i'm sorry i'm like i'm not
gonna be someone like it feels pathetic
to me to be in love with someone who
will will never and can never love you
in the way that you need to be loved
that just was a foreign concept to me i
go how can you even pitch that to me can
i run that same thought by you about
chef because now you felt like maybe
chef was a possible soul mate oh yeah
and now he's gone but he could love me
at the time i don't i don't i'm not like
i can't now because he's gone oh right i
mean i know i know that it's i'm
grieving what could have been as my
manager put it because that's the thing
i got it it's what's frustrating about
that death and listen i was really
surprised by how deeply that affected me
but you know you know how sometimes
you're you break up with someone who
you're seeing for two months and that
breakup was way harder than like a
partner of five years i don't know if
you've ever had that experience but i
mean they also you haven't didn't know
them long enough to have all the bad
parts so you're only grieving the good
parts you're i'm i was grieving
basically a perfect a perfect connection
with someone which yes in my logical
mind i know it would not have been
perfect and
i know about the lifestyle he led and
i'm sure it would have pissed me and he
would have pissed me off in a lot of
ways
and he would have partied too hard and i
would have been [ __ ] annoyed but i
would have eaten a lot of good food
um
uh
but so yeah i just i was in bed for like
two months just
really grieving that i think was also
another hard hit after
um
after the mental mental health loss of
you know
the as i say like the still greatest
love of my life
even though i hate them um i mean it's
huge of you to still be able to say that
because i don't know that i could get
past
to say the great greatest love of my
life and hate the person at the same
time my mom
is always mad at me for continuing to
talk about him because she's like you're
giving him
uh
power and like letting him know that
you care
care and i go but that's the truth
and also i'm looking at it more about
who you are like
power you have to be able to say look
i'm going to be vulnerable enough to say
this guy's greatest love of my life but
i'm going to be strong enough to also
say i can't stand them i hate that
[ __ ] i don't think there's
anything weak about saying someone hurt
me i am hurt
there's nothing weak about saying that i
know yeah and i'm really hurt and i just
but the part that blows me away is i
don't think anyone that's ever hurt me
like that i could still say
is the love of my life yeah well i mean
what it is
yeah i mean like but the thing is it's
just like yeah i mean like
even though i don't i don't even know
that i think he's a good person but
yeah that was
deepest connection i've ever felt with
someone and that's just
i i'm not like if i would if i
was left as the screenwriter of this
story i would have written it
differently but these are the facts and
like i said like in all areas of life
news personal relationships to me the
truth is the most important thing and
i'll figure out how to deal with it i
want to know the truth even when someone
breaks up with me tell me why tell me
why i can decide to fix it or not fix it
i can decide something something that i
also don't like about myself or that
just makes us not compatible i really i
just i like answers even like i'm a hard
client to have because agents love to
cuddle you and i go no tell tell me did
they think i was too fat am i not pretty
enough am i not good enough what's the
reason you know what's the reason if
it's because i'm not pretty enough well
i'm not fixed i'm not changing my face
but if it's because
you know um my acting chops just aren't
there well then i can go take a class
and i'm happy to you know i just want to
know the reason that's it
even if it hurts it's better to have the
real information i don't want to live i
don't want to live in lies
it's not it's not conducive to growth in
any way
even if it hurts i'm just like so tired
of living
people live so often to
protect themselves or to protect other
people when in reality i think like if
we just let the people people take the
hits we would all be a lot stronger
just take a minute hell yeah yeah i
agree
i think that i i say all the time every
every little boy at least should have
his ass kicked once in his life before
he gets to be a man and it would change
this place for the better dude i can't
believe i haven't been hit yet you've
never been hit no i've had a lot of
death threat i had a pretty serious
death threat though wow that's crazy
though that's way different i had like a
very public comedy community where a lot
like the terrorism unit of the nypd how
to get involved what yeah yeah yeah i
just was telling the story the other day
this guy this guy threatened to kill me
with the guillotine
that's exciting you gotta get you you
gotta put you in that [ __ ]
somebody's gotta make sure you stay like
that's that's why i said how vintage
i was gonna be a public gathering too
oh my god i was like
lipstick on my teeth i can't talk
anymore sorry i went to jumbo's clown
last night for the first time great spot
i haven't been there that's why my voice
sounds like this years that's this is
still a fun spot
all right good it was super fun i was
like i see they're like lipstick on my
teeth that's gonna be my next traumatic
story
um
where are we in life yeah well so far
you've lost the two loves yeah one for
sure one potential yeah um and there's
more loss on this list
it's so nice to have someone have a
screw like a screen of your trauma right
there look at it it's your bullet points
with child the bullet points
really is doing it for me that's what's
really doing it for me my vision [ __ ] so
it's gotta be real you're just squinting
and like my dad died um okay fun
look how long we've been going and we
haven't even gotten anywhere near your
list and i'd have to respect your time
so yeah no it's what i mean we could
fast forward tell me whatever you want
to tell me uh
where are we now in life okay oh yeah
actually
dad dying is next um
great we're right on schedule
um
so
lord almighty um
so what is it
it's november 16th 2020 is where we're
at now okay yeah so november 16th 2020
um
um i get off you know we're doing
rooftop shows it's coved in new york um
i had my phone on silent because i was
on a rooftop for new york comedy club i
get off stage turn my phone on message
from my mom
text message from my mom and a voicemail
from my mom and the text messages like
um she's a teacher so she's like she
like
she was like uh call me immediately it's
very important and urgent and i go [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] died
you know yes of course my mom my mom
notoriously has the worst poker face
epography is so bad you could see it
through a text message a non-poker face
so bad you could see it through a text
message um
and so
i called her
and she told me that my dad uh had a
heart attack later on i would find out
it was actually cardiac arrest which is
there's a you know there's he like he
was dead for like 20 minutes
um
uh on a golf course in new jersey uh
which is honestly i'm so thankful there
are so many
he um he owned a baseball card store for
many years in rosa park new jersey that
i actually have since taken over it's in
westchester now facebook cards are back
yeah yeah i mean that's a whole other
thing that i spent a lot of time doing
and i'm very passionate about but
uh yeah so i'm so thankful that he was
in a space uh with friends where they
could call because you know to have come
home my mom come home and found him
dead uh in the house or uh you know him
like dead alone in the store just like
what is that even thinking of that is
just like this just saddest thing
especially knowing who my dad was and a
person who liked to be surrounded unlike
me if i die alone please know i'm very
happy if you find my body alone with my
dog licking it weeks later just know
that's exactly how i want it to go
and do not feel sadness for me but if
but if my dad had been felt was found
like that it would have been
the worst and i guess the golf course
there's so many people around there
right you know if you needed help
there's a ton of people there it's
probably a good place to exactly and
there was someone actually um
in in the like a club who uh knew how to
do cpr so they were able to kind of
start it you know people when they say
they know cpr it's like okay you took i
took a class two once but like i have no
[ __ ] idea how to do it like i just
got did it for like a girl scout badge
um
and uh so yeah they
uh got the medics they came there
luckily he was pretty close to a
hospital and it took them
he was yeah he was dead for like i mean
they say 20 minutes i'm like can you
even come back from that but he did and
it took like a lot of time for them to
resuscitate him came back
yeah so he came back um he was in
i don't know if you would call it a coma
but like a non-responsive state
for
uh a couple of days and
so at that time i literally just stayed
in bed
for two
days
just
cr like unable to move crying stopping
trying to
figure out how
i'm gonna deal with him but i in my head
i was like he's not gonna die i just
don't i don't believe it i'm on my
computer in such a current move doing
medical research figuring out what they
what they should do
um
you know in retrospect i thought that
they should do this thing where they
lower your body temperature again i've
forgotten what all these things are
called my memory is actually really bad
right now because of my grief so i'm i
apologize for like the stuttering and
not remembering it's been a constant
[ __ ] problem um i like can't remember
people's names and
uh
that is a that's a major grief response
so it's so hard to do stand up i'm like
an old lady going on stage with notes
just because i can't [ __ ] remember
anything and i'm someone who used to
have a really good memory i could like
memorize the script for the school play
in one day
um but uh
yeah and like there's do they do this
thing where they lower your body
temperature basically so that your heart
doesn't have to work so hard um
and
even my mom asked in the emergency room
like do you do that and the reason they
ended up not doing it was because
if you are responsive they don't do it
so
he had a bodily response but later on um
a cardiologist was like well was it a
voluntary or an involuntary response
because a voluntary response yes you
don't do that procedure but an
involuntary response like basically
you're
you're you're jerking from the electric
shocks they're putting in you that's
different and it had been an involuntary
response so
all kinds of fuck-ups there and like i
don't know
i i don't want to be the person who like
self-diagnoses on webmd but the fact
that me with zero medical knowledge
came to the conclusion that that's what
should have been done
that's the sore spot i'm not i can't
dwell on the past though you know it's
not
that's what happened happened and he was
obviously his heart was in bad condition
anyway smoker since he was 12 it's fine
um 12. yeah um
so you know born in 1951 baby uh
and then uh
and then so yes crying in bed for two
days day three i'm like you have to get
up and do something you crying in bed is
not helping anyone
make a game plan do something there
anything you can do
so and the wise the whitest white woman
move my life i go to the witchcraft
store in my neighborhood i can't even
believe i'm telling you this
i show up it's coveted so you can't go
inside shops i show up in sweats
uh i'm a 30 how old am i at that time
35 i just turned 35
yeah i just turned 35 uh i gr grown ass
woman show up to the witchcraft store
crying
are you outside like outside the
witchcraft store
you have
cried into a mask which i think is all
of us at this point crying into him just
crying you're choking you're choking on
your own tears it's coming in the mouth
you go oh this is terrible
i get on my phone because you have to
call so someone comes out i'm i'm
whimpering on the phone
i'm the woman she goes uh i'll be right
out
the [ __ ] witch comes out
and she's like
what's going on and so and i'm sobbing
i'm sobbing and just one thing about
being a new yorker for 18 years you have
no problem crying in public i am an oh
i'm not even a open person i will ball
publicly anywhere
don't won't bat an eyelash so i'm
outside the witchcraft store and i'm
like
so i needed to get one of these
ceremonial candles which didn't seem
crazy to me because my my crystals
i don't believe in crystals
ryan um uh i don't believe in crystals
i'm not a dumb [ __ ] um
we're talking about a candle with
glitter in it right now
and i need you to be [ __ ] serious i'm
sorry let me dial it back all right i
need to be serious
a potion
yes a crystal let's not be childish
um so
it's so sad because like i literally
feel exactly that way and i know it's
insane um
so
so i tell her what's happening through
gasps and
she says well we usually can't give
these like ceremonial can you usually
you can only request from one for
yourself because like they take this
power you know very seriously as you
should with anything um
and but but i think she was like
so scared by how i might react by
telling me that i couldn't have a candle
that she like she said but because you
know your dad is unresponsive and can't
do it for himself she you know she made
some witchy reason in her head
she was like
that sounds like a sales pitch too
so they do they i give them the
information you have to give like i
guess i don't know what information
about him i needed like a healing candle
so they're like carving you know snakes
into a candle and green glitter glitter
healing and while the witch was working
on that i actually did go to the crystal
store that's how dark the times were
that they sent me i think they just
wanted me to not cry in front of the
store for 20 minutes while they were
carving the candle so they sent me to
the crystal store
so i did go to the crystal store because
that's how desperate i was when crystals
start getting involved you know i am
no pun intended at rock bottom and so i
was at rock bottom at the crystal store
and
then i came back and i got the candle
and i lied and it's one of those candles
i liked it because it's it's similar to
a lot of
to jewish costumes don't just gloss over
would you gif did you just shut
did you just eye candy at the at the
crystal store no you got it
oh i got crestos i think i got like a
tiger's eye and an and an arrow is that
those little ones i see sometimes the
tiger's eye looks literally like like
the orange and black uh pattern the same
way like a tiger print rug would uh what
is that what is that it was all like
healing protection i don't remember i
can never remember the crystals i mean i
just put the rocks in addition and i go
well this meant something i it had
purpose at one time and then you know
you rinse it off with some water and you
put it in the moisture and i've had some
moon water too yeah
you have that moon water you know just
you know it's like i don't do i believe
in it but it's like if the moon's out
might we'll make something but does it
work i don't know but why not give it a
[ __ ]
moon water isn't gonna hurt anymore
so i drink it in the morning
wait you drink moon water every day no
in the morning i said i'll leave it out
overnight so when is they fall off yeah
morning water good for you good for you
thank you um i'm a little dialed in do
it i'm witch-ish yeah yeah i love it
lean in um and uh
this is not what cheryl sandberg met
when she said lean in but okay
um
oh my god i can't sometimes the stuff is
coming out of my mouth and it's like
hold on i do feel this way we've left
the crystal shot we're now back to the
camera i'm back at the witch store um i
thought of the cable shop that was nice
of you um and yeah and i get it and it's
you know and then i go home and i burn
it and it's like it burns for
like ten days in my say i left a candle
burning in my you know my sink is metal
so for ten days and like i said like i
really i liked it and it felt right for
my dad because he is jewish and you know
when you a person
dies who's jewish you know you'll go
light the candle and leave it out in
memorial so
that's the thing like it it did feel
jewish in some ways so i'm like
even though my when i am religious my
chosen religion truly is wicca it's the
only because it's nature-based so it's
like it just feels realer to me um
and again they're kind of all religions
are kind of the same but uh
and then so i left that and i'm praying
and i'm doing everything i'm just doing
doing anything i can think of sending
good energy emailing like prayer groups
across the country because it's like
my
my response to something is never going
to be do nothing that's not who i am but
i'm also like not a doctor
like so what do i just go what do what
can i do and i do believe in energy
so
it's like you i just had to do something
because i said me cry sitting in bed
crying um
is not doing anything and it's making
the situation about me and this isn't
about me right now and let's just try
what we can do and also during that time
i was also reading up in preparation for
like um
because again i really believe that he
would come to again and how are we going
to get through this as a family and he
did were you allowed to visit at all did
you go sit outside
not at that time i mean it was like yeah
no no no no no like my mom had been a
little bit well you would have that's
even more mind [ __ ] yeah my mom that's
why then that's why i hadn't gone home
to new jersey because my i was like i my
mom said you can of course but i just
didn't think and like knowing my
personality my mom's personality i just
didn't think that me sitting at home
crying was gonna be helpful to my mom
when she was obviously under stress um
so and she and they you know they have a
dog there so i was like you can you know
you have you have support through that
i'm like certainly me coming home and
crying all over your house it's not
going to be helpful in any way um and so
uh
yeah a couple days come by on like the
third day
there's eye movement he's responsive
right you know fast forward he's so i
mean and this goes on for months and
months and months so he finally becomes
responsive i do end up visiting him
like around when did i get to visit him
i guess thanksgiving was the first time
i was able to visit him in the hospital
and you could you could only go two
visitors a day one at a time and that's
it you had to sign in so of course it's
me and my mom my brother lives in
california so he hadn't been home yet at
this point because they were just mine
was like no point you know you literally
can't come in the room um so we would
try to facetime and stuff and i mean i
remember vividly the fir walking into
the hospital room the first time i saw
my dad and
he had brain damage so he didn't know
who i was you know and so
obviously there's a lot of things where
you know you're a lot of people have had
experiences where their parents slowly
forget who they are and who the kids are
but
for overnight someone to forget who you
are and their entire life especially
the smartest person i've ever met this
is a man who got um a perfect score on
the math sat actually he got one wrong
on the math s.a.t but he claims that
they were wrong and i think they
actually it was like a mistake on the
test and this is like one of the
funniest stories about him but yes so
this is a [ __ ]
genius of a man um and i think when
someone is so associated with their like
when i like i just think my dad i think
his mind
so to have that be the loss was like
that's a tough pill to swallow and i
mean it was just me like going behind a
curtain sobbing and then going back and
like you know you don't want to sob over
the person even though he wouldn't have
even processed it i don't think but i
mean he was it wasn't like he was out of
it he was a human being but like kind of
like a child-like human being who was
just existing and so i was like i'll
just treat this as if i'm
visiting a new person you know i know
who he is he doesn't know who i am but
that doesn't mean you know i can't
[ __ ] i relate to people i don't know
every night that's literally my
occupation i can do this um
and
so it was just
a lot with visits like that for weeks
you know i'm like uh taking the train to
new jersey to go to the hospital as much
as i possibly can and like i really like
i put my career completely on hold at
the point i don't give a [ __ ] um
and uh visiting him a lot and just
trying to jar his memory uh in different
ways uh the first time uh after several
visits i was able to get something out
of him that connected was we were
playing beatles music and he was able to
continue hey jude on his own the lyrics
so the first thing that came about
was music
so we were playing all his favorites
cindy lauper um
joni mitchell
uh beatles like that's his that's his
music and so yeah and i i was so and the
minute he continued hey jude on his own
that's all i needed i was like yes we're
gonna do this then student current comes
back and i'm researching i'm pulling up
things i'm making playlists i'm finding
videos i'm finding old photos i'm like
we're gonna make this man's memory come
back we can [ __ ] do this i know we
can if any family can do it we can do it
so this goes on his memory does start
start coming back slowly he starts
wrecking like
me and my mom and my brother obviously
and he and his brother are the kind of
only people he ever
really ended up recognizing again but he
recognizes us it comes in and out um
and uh
at one point he did propose to me
because that when he didn't know who i
was and i was like flattered you are the
first man to ask but
i don't know how i feel about that and
you know
i'm a 35 year old woman so my friends
are like what did you say you know
i finally started talking about it on
stage and i'm like it's not lost on me
that the first man to propose was number
one my dad and number two had brain
damage so
i'll work on that i'll i
compartmentalize that i'll work on that
later
age
yeah or more yeah so um
yeah so that's coming back he finally he
finally in
like
we so we go through christmas he's still
in the hospital mary coming in and out
uh he he goes to like a rehab center
finally in i think it was february 2021
um he makes it home he's in he's well
enough to make it home have people in
and out my brother and i kind of
reschedule our entire lives to take
shifts because my mom couldn't handle it
alone and to add to all this my dad's
six foot six so just damn a really
like that's the same height as michael
jordan to put it into perspective really
skinny but six foot six um and so even
you know he couldn't he his
equilibrium's all off so even to lead
him around the house you almost need two
people just to be that tall and thank
god my brother's tall but me and my mom
are really short um
and so he's home he has uh people coming
uh like you know nurses coming but no
one's there full time except for the
family and my brother and i kind of just
take shifts so i'm there for
like almost
a week and then my brother flies in from
california to do his shift and during
that time i mean it was
i was crying a lot
kind of from exhaustion because like i
would have to wake up at like six in the
morning which for a comic was just
and you're dealing and you're just like
dealing with someone who you know who
you love but it's having like kind you
know there's brain damage there's wild
reactions to things sometimes he's just
grabbing your arm aggressively i'm never
scared of him because it's my dad but
you know it's just it's just you're
you're just constantly in a state of
shock and you don't really know how to
explain it to any of your friends and i
only found like one person that i knew
who had had a kind of a similar
experience her mom was in a pretty bad
car accident um so i knew a little bit
about what to expect but i didn't like i
didn't know this about cardiac arrest or
heart attacks i thought either you
live or you don't i didn't know there
was a part where you live and you have
brain damage i just didn't know that i
didn't i never knew that that was a
thing from
heart stuff i knew that was a thing from
like you know dead trauma um
and
then week two i go at the time i visit
i'm dating a comic in north carolina i
fly out to visit him my brother takes a
shift while
literally the moment i land in north
carolina i get a call that my dad went
into cardiac or rest again and i'm like
[ __ ] and so there was this constant uh
anxiety i had around about even leaving
and and then it was only reinforced
because literally the moment i left i'm
on a 90-minute plane and in that time
that i left something bad did happen
which is bad for anyone but especially
bad for a person with
obsessive-compulsive disorder because
obsessive compulsive disorder especially
the kind i have is literally just
thinking if you don't do things in a
certain way something bad is going to
happen to someone you love and even
though logically i know me getting on
that plane to north carolina had nothing
to do with that happening it's still
like your worst fear hap is your worst
like the worst part of your anxiety
disorder is coming true um
so then we go back to because i'm in
north carolina my mom's like there's no
point in flying back now he's just you
know he's we go through the process
again um this time they did the body
temperature cool down thing um
uh
and you know and this happened right
after he had really started to
acknowledge where he was i think going
home to his house where he lived really
lit up a lot of memories he had been
facetiming with his older brother things
were coming back he knew i was his
daughter like you know there was a lot
of mem a lot of memories still missing
but there were pieces there were pieces
there
and uh and i gotta say throughout the
whole the whole experience the one thing
that remained intact was the sense of
humor which was
a really interesting experience for me
as a stand-up comedian um and uh so i'm
on the fl i'm doing medita meditations
and trying to connect with him
spiritually on the bathroom floor of
this [ __ ] hotel that i'm in uh
visiting my my boyfriend i got a hotel
because i'm gonna stay in his house he
lived with his sister that's not another
part of the story though
that's another trauma mediating men in
their 40s who don't live by themselves
um
it's my own you have to come back for
that my own [ __ ] fault um
uh
and uh and then so we basically he does
come
come to uh from the from that stage uh
the cooldown but
we basically we're back to one he's back
to the same memory loss and experience
the first time and after that um
he's in the hospital for a couple months
and we're just not seeing a ton of
progress he has catherine is getting a
ton of utis just like everything that
they're it's not just the heart there's
just everything that can go wrong
is and you know then there's a higher
risk of covid there's there's just so
much going on staying in a hospital when
you're already sick is actually really
dangerous because you're surrounded by
sick people and people don't you don't
think of that but it's like you want to
really get the person out of the
hospital as soon as as soon as possible
but when they need so much assistance
for their heart
that's also hard so
we got him into some kind of i think a
reha like a rehab again it wasn't
working he's getting sick he's going
back to the hospital all the time this
keeps happening it's just like we're all
on edge every time the phone rings
something terrible is happening
and my dad is like i mean he has brain
damage but he's you know getting out of
his bed crawling around the hospital
floor like not being the best patient
but also he has brain damage and it
seemed like the medical professionals
around him like were reacting like this
was a completely cognizant grown
69 year old man crawling around the
floor and i'm like he has brain damage
like this is not like he's doing it to
[ __ ] with you yeah right
and i was just flabbergasted time and
time again about how
they were talking to him as if he was
just someone being difficult not someone
who had brain damage
i don't know
um i had to make conversations with with
nurses about this but whatever um
and then uh
you know we kind of we kind of all know
that thing at this point there's we've
done everything um and so my mom you
know calls has the facetime meeting for
me and my brother
to tell me um that she thinks we need to
put dad in hospice and
i am like it's for me haas the word
hospice feels like giving up uh yeah um
it also scares me i always feel like
everybody that goes in the hospice is
dead within like
four weeks of getting in there well
there's some actually i had watched this
thing surviving death on netflix and
someone like was like living basically
in a hospice state for like years and
years and years and she looked like she
was [ __ ] loving life but i'm like
i'm like there you go there's always one
yeah she's like tony hawk
[ __ ] were you like lonely or like what
happened here she looked great um
but whatever kudos to her
uh if you watch surviving death on
netflix it's amazing uh it really like
helped me i was like i was really
getting into like connecting with the
the afterlife in that realm because i
knew i would have to prepare you know
even if it wasn't
even if my dad had lit it would only be
maximum my dad was only going to live a
couple years best case scenario he was
only going to live like two years more
so i knew that i needed to start
preparing for his death but yeah so he's
in hospice i had already thought it on
my own so it made me it made me feel
like it wasn't like a haphazard decision
because i my mom and i
had
separately had the same thought that
like it's time for hospice and i think
like you you know when you think about
your final days you want them to be in a
nice place a hospital is not a night i'm
not like an anti-hospital person but a
hospital is not a nice place no hospice
is a nice honestly hospice is a nice
place it was it was comfortable it was a
nice hotel room like as i said a hotel
room not like a facility yeah i know
i've spent a lot of time in the comic in
hotel rooms it just felt like a hotel
room he had a beautiful window with a
garden like i'm like when i when i went
into there i go this is what i i would
want to look out the window and see this
if i'm going to die because he couldn't
be home that wasn't a choice we weren't
able to physically take care of him in
the way that he needed to be taken care
of um so yeah and then i just became
like me going almost every day to new
jersey spending
just an i mean
tens of thousands of dollars on ubers um
to because i just did to take the train
like it was so far i don't have a car
like that was the only way to
effectively be able to visit him and not
completely ruin the career that i had
worked on um uh and like living at home
no one wanted me home so that wasn't an
option either um but yeah and so i just
continued to do that and honestly
hospice was probably one of the more
positive experiences of this whole thing
because
my dad was in and out of knowing who i
was but like we had a lot of good times
in hospice when i just was like i'm
gonna just treat him as
again like we're just gonna make the
best of i'm not gonna go in and be sad
and we're just gonna have [ __ ] fun
one of my favorite memories in hospice
is um
my dad
turned and my dad was always like a
ladies man but obviously you have no
filter when you have brain damage so you
you know just really and hard as one of
the guys we [ __ ] women who has
fought so long and hard against sexual
assault and then him just being like you
know nice rack to the nurses to come in
he would tell you know maybe not that
accessible i don't know
i don't want to
tarnish his name in the afterlife but he
you know he would tell all the hospice
nurses that he was a porn star
um and then my mom would be like randy
and he would be like i'm sorry you're
right i just owned a sex shop
like really the funniest when i first
showed up at hospice he starts yelling
down the hallway come in my daughter's
here come get an autograph well you can
smile [ __ ]
like a fun because and that was what was
so important like even though most of
randy was missing like my favorite part
and the part that certainly inspired me
the most was like still so alive and it
was like wow so like music and and humor
is this powerful then even after you've
been dead they've brought you back to
life two times
you're that it's so strong that it comes
through and it wasn't a generic sense of
humor it was still like his he has like
a
like kind of a mischievous like i'm
gonna say the most [ __ ] see how [ __ ]
up of a thing i can say to you like it's
a very
he's not like a dad funny he's like
stand up comedian funny um
and so there was a lot of that we one
time uh i convinced he was always trying
to get out of bed and stuff and again
like six foot six this is so much to
handle so one of my favorite memories
was i told him that he was going on a
date with a hot lady later that day we
and he's in his like it was like a
wheelchair but they lock you in with
like a table so you can't get out i
don't know what exactly it's called but
he was in that and he just would always
try to get out of it um but it was
better than being in a bed because you
got to sit up for once better for the
blood flow you know blood flow is so
important with a heart issue um and so i
would have to distract him and i decided
that he was going on a date i said like
the limo was coming we were picking we
we got i like took flowers from the
vases in hospice i was like you have to
give this to your date we're change
we're changing his outfit into a new
thing i'm combing his hair i made him
post for a picture like we really did it
and so it was just fun because i'm like
i saw a lot of people visiting hospice
and they were kind of just like sitting
with their loved ones and i'm like
that's fine i'm not gonna i can't
criticize how you decide
i was [ __ ] coming in like a preschool
teacher with a [ __ ] plan every time
i'm like we're gonna play a game we're
gonna sing a song i interviewed him at
one point wrote down the answers i'm
like i don't care if they're wild i'm
curious i don't care that recorded um oh
it was a handwritten interview like i
was a journalist yeah i we made videos
we watched a lot of deal or no deal a
lot of jeopardy things that he really
liked because again like a numbers man
mental stimulation stealer no deal he
seemed to like you know and it's good
because it's a show where you can root
for people we did get to see someone win
the million we're cheering
you know just like stuff like that
um yeah and then uh that he was there
for a couple of months and like there's
a couple of times like they know when
right when you're about to die basically
um
and that's like a different state that
you know hospice nurses are trained to
recognize and so
where there was one false alarm i take
you know my mom calls me she says i
think it's time um i of course get in an
uber immediately go to hospice uh i get
there and i get in my dad's like kicking
around laughing i go
i go
who's who said that he was dying i was
like this he looks honestly better than
he's been in weeks and then everyone
leaves a room and i was like well i've
already i'm already here so i'll sleep
over with you because you're um during
like this this final um
days of death you're you don't have any
restrictions on how long you can visit
family is allowed to be there 24 7.
basically you just have to call and let
them know that you're going to come
everyone should go to this [ __ ]
hospice yeah it was unlike any hospice
story i've ever heard oh really i mean
can i yeah i'm sorry to be insensitive
real quick but we're going for an hour
and 20. we got to do yeah what time is
it right now 109.
what time you got to get out of here i
need to go we need to be
oh yeah we probably need to like wrap
right yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't want
to i mean oh my gosh i can tie a ribbon
on it it's sure we're almost done i mean
we're we're moments from history i rush
you to tell the story of the father
we're moments from his death this is
great we've timed the screen i have a
bfa and directed
it's all good it's
moments this one was a trick so i go i i
basically i was like dad are you [ __ ]
with them and then i was like are you
pretending to die and then we had a
laugh was he i i mean again too much
brain damage to get a straight answer
but it sure seemed like
that's actually pretty interesting
and i was like
i was like you're a troublemaker and i
respect it um and then yeah
and then
uh yeah i left to see my boyfriend in
north carolina one more time of course
come back immediately as soon as i land
get a call i'd actually get a call that
he's again this time for real in the
final stages
of life um i would ended up being the
last person to see him alive from the
family um
and he was it was the only time we're in
hospice where was really hard to be
around because it was the only time that
he seemed just so sick just so i mean he
was weak and i mean his his legs were
the size of my arm truly um
oh yeah withering withering away i mean
um
yeah it just you know to see someone
truly evaporate in front of your eyes a
really really one of my grandmothers
died like that and i was honestly i know
exactly i was scared to hug her yeah i
felt like i would break all her bones if
i squeezed her yeah just just an
absolutely wild experience to have and
um so yeah he passes uh
yeah he passed away and we had he was
basically coughing for most of my last
visit because you know just the fluids
are coming up um but yeah i like i kind
of just knew and i before i like left i
was like i'm gonna come see you in two
days um
but i was like if you feel like you need
you need to go you can go like i'm i'm
okay with that um
and uh damn it we almost made it i know
you love cr tier 4 i don't love it i
know you you go a jerk off at home it
says i [ __ ] know trust me when i tell
you this is not a monster i walked in
and i was like you can't cry you can't
give this man what he loves
we know male comedians are [ __ ]
predators
um and we can't give them this i don't
know
at least i would rather have tears than
anything else and then and then he uh
and i you know i i said i was very
cinematic i literally said it i love you
i gave him a kiss on the forehead uh
walked out of hospice and he i thought
he couldn't respond and then right as
i'm like passing through the frame of
the door i hear him go love you and i go
nice and i you just know there's such a
like i just [ __ ] knew every part of
this it was like really like i had call
i knew that in my head i had june when
as soon as he had a cardiac arrest in
november
immediately the the vision the thing
that came into my mind was i said to
myself well no more in june he died june
29th that was the first thought i had
months before i go my family kept asking
questions i go i i go i don't know what
to tell you i just say i said i know
we'll know more in june i know we'll
know more in june and we did i mean it
was not great news but it was fine and
i'm really fortunate that i had a lot of
um time
um with him because my mom kind of
always said it's like you know it's like
yeah it's not the same version of him
but this is how he is at this stage in
his life and so we need to appreciate
him at 100
you know then i go to costa rica more
his death during that time i'm i i wake
up in the middle of the night with the
same kind of carl jolt and i find out
that my childhood best friend had died
uh two years prior and i didn't know and
what that's a wrap everybody hold on sit
there for a second that's a wrap first
of all thank you
that's uh
back to one advice you would give to
your 16 year old self because i do want
to hear that and then promote whatever
you want
wrap it
my 16 year old self i say [ __ ] you keep
practicing that oscar speech in the
mirror because you're going to get there
so i love my 16 year old self and i love
me now and i
don't change a thing you're going to be
a spice girl and you're going to win an
oscar
i love
it and don't let anyone [ __ ] dim your
dim your light or tell you that you're
too [ __ ] cocky or a narcissist you're
exactly the way you need to be
that's great and uh yeah and not at all
yeah i'm on all social media tik tok
instagram twitter
at philanthropygal
um it's tongue-in-cheek i don't think
i'm like [ __ ] giving back to the
universe guys just no one can [ __ ]
spell my name right so i had to do a
word that you can look up in the
dictionary philanthropy gal and uh most
importantly uh watch our special day
it's uh christina hutchinson and my
debut comedy special on youtube you can
access it for free youtube.com guys we
[ __ ] without the you in [ __ ] real
real labor of love and i think even even
if you don't think it's funny like it's
cool that artists are making their own
[ __ ] um so you know watch it give it a
like and uh and then guys we [ __ ]
podcasts uh it's a it's a luminary
podcast but it's you know available on
the luminary channel on apple podcasts
for free
um
yeah guys we fought the
anti-slut-shaming podcast i truly really
think it's one of the best podcasts out
there and i'm not someone who thinks
everything she does is great i really
think it's a great podcast and i think
that anyone can get something out of it
my mom even likes to share [ __ ] like
well thank you for doing this
as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you